bonjour à tous et bienvenue à l'heure
des prochaines ont la flemme le covid
les confinements ont changé notre
rapport au travail l'Ifop et la
Fondation Jean Jaurès on mené une étude
auprès des Français 41% de nos
compatriotes sont moins motivés dans
leur vie quotidienne bien au-delà que le
travail pour cette vente source d'info
on continue
la commerce c'est bon les consultations
psy augmentent le nombre d'arrêts
maladies explosent la télétravail le
télétravail s'impose plus télé que
travail la livraison à domicile remplace
la balade au marché les aquabonistes
prospère les démotivés pullulent les
dépressifs affluent merci covid vous
pouvez prendre le pass et aller en salle
des ventes merci beaucoup c'est bien si
vous êtes des vacances
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas assez de
personnes différentes à la télévision
une question à te poser ma chérie est-ce
qu'il a un beau stabilo dans le slip
maman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a beaucoup de mosquées
[Rires]
vous êtes trop
Karine Karine vous vous pensez qu'il y
en a combien
mon dieu c'est pas un chiffre Karine
monsieur errant 17e fois qu'il y a une
évacuation et à chaque fois le camp se
reconstitue à chaque fois des migrants
reviennent par centaines on sera bien
sûr sur place dès le début de mardi vous
le savez hier nous devions être en
direct cette fois du centre de migrants
de Gien on a prévu de rentrer avec
Stéphane Ravier sénateur des
Bouches-du-Rhône qui sera en direct avec
tout dans un instant alors oui Stéphane
Ravier sénateur de la République peut
rentrer avec des journalistes et une
caméra comme n'importe quel élu la loi
lui autorise mais évidemment pas
question de faire ça en direct le C le
mot d'origine arabe employé par les
jeunes pour dire bien fait pour toi
je sais désormais pourquoi la préfecture
du Var ne voulait pas que ces news
réalise indirect dans ce centre de
clando là-bas la presqu'île de Gien
alors c'est pas pour dire pour assurer
leur anonymat pour préserver la
confidentialité de je ne sais trop quoi
c'est pas ce qu'ils étaient en train de
jouer au foot les clandestins c'était en
train de jouer au foot voyez là ils sont
pas au bord du gouffre je ne sais pas si
c'était des érythréens qui gagnaient
contre les Somaliens mais voilà c'est là
c'est la joie de vivre c'est le bonheur
donc il fallait pas que ça se voit ces
mots du golioris qui ne portera pas de
brassard aux couleurs de la communauté
LGBT alors que le président de l'AFF
Noël le Grete a déconseillé aux joueurs
de porter un brassard arc-en-ciel pour
soutenir la cause LGBT je comprends pas
c'est à dire qu'il nous en permanence en
disant qu'on a pas de coeur qu'on est
tout le temps en stratégie alors qu'au
final on n'a pas de stratégie on est
sincère on est gentil et au final on
s'en prend plein la gueule bien sûr j'ai
mon opinion personnelle et
ça rejoint un petit peu celle du
président pour ce justifier le gardien
de 35 ans explique qu'il compte
respecter la culture du Qatar
donc une coordination est pourtant
toujours des espèces humaines merci
merci de nous accepter comme nous sommes
se marier ce joueur de foot biélorus en
a fait un but à la fin du match il a
voulu faire sa demande à sa bien-aimée
sauf que normalement personne ne doit
rentrer sur le terrain installé à
appliquer cette consigne peut-être un
peu trop pied de la lettre en chassant
le rose élu heureusement tout est rentré
dans l'ordre demande accepter pas trop
stressé
de faire la fête
[Musique]
de découvrir ma future femme non non pas
sûr de faire la fête il est formidable
[Applaudissements]
bonne ambiance à Beaujon il y avait
quand même 8 personnes un nouveau
millésime très goûtu mais il n'y en aura
pas pour tout le monde c'est quand même
la mauvaise nouvelle avec la sécheresse
la production a baissé de 20%. l'année
dernière il est très très fruité et vu
avec le changement climatique il est
de meilleures dernières années
[Applaudissements]
hier au téléphone un peu sur le ton de
la rigolade mais quand même avec une
pointe de vérité depuis qu'on a interdit
le vin dans les cantines et bien c'est
une succession d'interdiction qui touche
au volant enfin tout ça des fêtes
toujours d'actualité comme certains
messages de lucidité
de manière à ne pas influer le déficit
de la Sécurité sociale
ça marche à peu près tout quand vous
êtes un peu les Colisée quand vous êtes
souvent alcoolisé ça ouais là
ce soir ce soir il est il est au boulot
donc le ministre des Transports picole
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre il y a 15000 soignants
suspendus
pompiers et gendarmes qui n'attendent
qu'une chose c'est qu'on les réintègre
comme ils l'ont fait à New York et comme
ils l'ont fait en Italie qu'est-ce qu'on
attend qu'est-ce qu'on attend
15000 soignants prêts à travailler mais
mon dieu il faudrait des soignants
va-t-on en trouver va-t-on en trouver
enfin enfin
ils sont là ils sont là sans salaire
sans rien sans chômage
c'est courageux parce qu'il y a que des
coups à prendre